What is LinkedIn and why does it matter?
LinkedIn is the world's largest
professional online network
with over 300 million users.
Notably, it's quite different
than a traditional resume,
whereas your resume highlights
your career at a glance.
LinkedIn paints a vivid portrait of
you no matter what your background.
LinkedIn has multiple functions, for
example, many recruiters increasingly
use LinkedIn to connect with candidates.
Your profile can be a great way to
market your accomplishments online and
get noticed by employers and
apply to jobs.
LinkedIn can also help to strengthen
your profession network and
learn about industry trends.
Since many industry leaders are active
contributors to the LinkedIn community,
LinkedIn often features
interesting articles,
talks and
quotes from industry thought leaders.
It can also be a great place to initiate
informational interviews, network, and
see what your peers
are up to professionally.
A strong LinkedIn profile
is a powerful tool to have,
is your profile doing
everything you needed to do?